right well the downtown area was really
hit hard a lot of business owners were
mopping up sweeping up their storefronts
today preparing for as we've mentioned
even more storms this weekend that's
right our very own madison kimbrough
stopped by some of those businesses she
is live near imperial and commerce with
what they experienced medicine
yeah it's very very hot out here right
now but it was a much needed late night
downpour last night as a lot of the
business owners that you see right here
were left this morning tending to the
mess left
behind what did you come to work to this
morning what did you find a lot of
flooding barber and tattoo shop owner
rob snyder of imperial dtlv had quite
the mess to clean up this morning at his
shop snyder a new business owner says he
found water had seeped through the back
door last night along with a leak in the
ceiling of course all things can be
expected when your business is in an
older building as many are in the arts
district whenever it rains like
all of a sudden you discover holes in
the roof that you forgot about six
months ago because they don't want
brands like this every once in a while
and councilwoman olivia diaz of ward 3
which spans downtown and the arts
district says while the rain is much
needed it's important that the city is
prepared there are projects in the works
with the city of las vegas in terms of
increasing our capacity for
drain storms and obviously projects
i wish they could be done overnight but
that kind of scope and scale take
sometimes a year year and a half to
complete
and while all the businesses that you
see right here stopped
where they were fully able to open back
up today some neighbors went to bed and
woke up with leaky roofs and